[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport ce magazine consacré comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département à ces parties a pour le
sommaire rugby versailles réalisé une
superbe saison en s'inclinant en quart
de finale du championnat de france
honneur
retour sur cette performance et sur
l'avenir du club dans cette édition avec
le responsable aux communications du
club pierre chevallier un solide
insolites des bolides miniatures se sont
affrontés à maurepas ce week-end à
l'occasion de la 4e manche du
championnat de france des courses
voitures radiocommandées au total près
de cent pilotes se sont affrontés sur le
circuit mort pas un reportage à suivre
cyclisme mantes-la-jolie sort à
l'honneur cette semaine les championnats
de france sur route sont organisées dans
la ville à partir de ce jeudi 28 juin
jusqu'au dimanche 1er juillet au
programme trois jours de compétition qui
ont rassemblé plus de 600 power coup de
projecteur dans ce magazine l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tb 78
[Musique]
on commence donc par de la boxe les
yvelinois ont brillé ce week-end le
champion olympique des poids lourds tony
yoka originaires de chanteloup les
vignes a remporté samedi au palais des
sports de paris son cinquième combat
chez les professionnels en dominant
l'anglais david allen par arrêt de
l'arbitré à la 10e reprise
le français de 26 ans gagne pour la
quatrième fois avant la limite dans
l'autre match de la soirée le franco
marocain ahmed el moussaoui a remporté
son combat contre le russe alexey cecco
alias europe qui on l'a pas encore sur
les images on va le voir dans un instant
double champion d'europe champion de
russie il a été déclaré vainqueur suite
à décision unanime des trois juges
avec cette victoire le boxeur de la
verrière conserve sa place parmi l'élite
des poids welters en pointant au 18e
rang 1 mondial à notre avis noah était
sur le devant de la scène sportive ce
week-end en aviron le versailles et
thomas barrau qui a décroché une belle
quatrième place en finale avec son
coéquipier pierre ou en deux de couple
poids léger lors d'une manche de coupe
du monde à linz en autriche
ils ont été devancés par les équipages
italiens norvégien et belge les
satisfactions sont grandes pour les deux
français qui n'avaient jamais concouru
ensemble en compétition internationale
on écoute la réaction par téléphone de
lévis noah thomas baruch première à
l'ensemble paraît vraiment positive même
si on est les premiers à être déçus
lettres retrait de faire quatre plutôt
que pour te voilà il ya près d'une
seconde avec la médaille avec la
troisième place on aurait fait médaille
on va première sortie internationale que
monde aurait été formidable
les deux tricolores on nous aurons une
nouvelle occasion de monter sur le
podium dans trois semaines sur l'étape
de coupe du monde suisse de lucerne pour
leur deuxième régate internationale
ensemble ce week-end ont fêté la journée
de l'olympisme samedi matin la ministre
des sports laura flessel était au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
dans le cadre de cette journée elle a pu
rencontrer à cette occasion les acteurs
politiques et sportives du territoire
pour évoquer ce site qui a été retenue
pour accueillir les épreuves de cyclisme
sur piste pour les jeux olympiques de
paris en 2024
la femme politique en a également
profité pour assister au départ de
courses pédestres et de cyclisme en
hausse aux rondes sur les manifestations
organisées ce week-end à paris un mot de
rugby y est à présent ce samedi le club
de montigny le bretonneux a enfin
inauguré son nouveau pôle sportif au
stade roger couderc
au projet dans les cartons depuis le
début des années 2000 aujourd'hui deux
terrain synthétique flambant neufs non
homologué pour les compétitions sont
désormais accessibles aux joueurs du
club
coût total de l'opération 1,3 million
d'euros on écoute les réactions micro de
nicolas doré ça va permettre de
s'entraîner correctement tout l'hiver
à titre d'exemple cette saison terrain
en herbe est resté fermé un mois et à
montigny il n'y a pas de gymnase de
pajin doses disponibles
donc on est resté un mois sans traîner
ça va permettre de jouer de jouer des
matchs sur les terrains synthétiques
l'hiver je pense que l'entraînement les
joueurs reviendront plus volontiers en
sachant qu'ils vont pas finir avec cinq
centimètres de boue sur le corps créé
des terrains synthétiques aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose qui coûte
effectivement beaucoup d'argent mais il
faut quand même savoir que sur montigny
on a onze mille onze mille sportifs
jeudi par 11 me le rugbyman mais en
mille sportifs
donc on se doit aussi de leur donner des
installations qui sont et de leur
permettre de pratiquer les terrains
étaient également baptisé le porteront
le nom de pierre à paillasse ancien
adjoint au maire délégué aux sports à
monti le bretonneux décédé l'année
dernière
l'homme politique avait également été
président de l'asm des rugbys de 1981 à
on continue à parler de rugby après un
superbe parcours verser s'est incliné en
quart de finale du championnat de france
honneur contre chalon sur saône sur
terrain neutre les joueurs de la cité
royale ont été battus 11 à 0 avec un
manque d'efficacité au pied qui leur
coûte le match pour nous parler de ce
match nous recevons le responsable
communication du club pierre chevallier
qui est un habitué de ce plateau car il
intervient régulièrement sur l'émission
si on parlait sport bonsoir pierre conte
avec michael ça va très bien alors est
ce que vous avez eu le temps d'analyser
cette défaite
oui désormais avec le recul on a on a pu
voir ce qui est ce qu'il y avait pêché
sur un sur un beau trajet de phase
finale
comme vous le précisez il ya eu
effectivement un manque de réalisme et
un manque d'efficacité au pied notamment
sur pénalité au moment au moment où
versailles était dans les temps forts on
perd on perd contre une belle équipe de
chalon avec avec les honneurs en honneur
puisque
puisque sur le score de 11 à 0 faut le
comparer par exemple à l'équipe
l'équipe de saint nazaire qui a perdu en
demie contre chalon avec harnecker de
quasiment 25 points nous avons pris 40
mois après finalement au chalon s'est
incliné en finale le week-end dernier
mais ce contre cette belle équipe
effectivement maintenant avec le recul
c'est un pansement de un manque
d'efficacité un manque de réalisme pas
forcément un manque de fraîcheur mais on
va dire les aléas des fascias les matchs
un petit peu au couteau avec avec
quelques quelques matches qui se jouent
qui se joue au détail
c'est une défaite encourageante si je
peux dire c'est très rageant c'est très
à la mode de ce qu'on retiendra de toute
façon c'est que c'est fait c'est une
défaite à un niveau historique pour le
club
c'était la première fois qu'une équipe
senior du rcv atteignait les quarts de
finale en honneur donc avec le voile à
cesser les joueurs ont marqué les cas l
équipe de l'histoire du club avec leur
staff
et puis défaite encourageante on je
dirais je dirais non parce que parce
qu'on aurait vraiment aimé encore plus
la marque et cette histoire du club et
qu'elle est vraiment vraiment le plus
loin possible
il y avait la place quand on voit quand
on voit justement les équipes qui qui
perdent autour fila au tour au tour
d'après
les scénarios qui ce qui sonne qui se
sont tramés il y avait peut-être la
place de passer surtout par rapport aux
prestations qu'on avait fourni jusqu'à
ce moment là cette défaite est ce que ça
vous condamnent vraiment dans la course
à la montée en fédérale 3 il y avait une
petite chance je crois devoir versailles
encore en fédérale 3 surtout au niveau
administratif ainsi voilà c'est ça qu'il
y avait au début de la saison il y avait
deux chances la première la première qui
était la plus on va dire la plus à la
fois la plus difficile mais là plus
la plus imaginable c'était de finir
premier de poule
l'un finalement on termine 3e de poule
derrière sarcelles et bagneux et la
deuxième chance c'était d'aller le plus
loin possible pour espérer qu'il reste
des places de monter dans le tableau
final à partir des quarts de finale on a
vu assez vite après notre victoire
contre le mans en 8e qu'il n'y avait
plus plus beaucoup de place il en reste
une à une à attribuer donc oui oui
concrètement ça donne ça nous condamnent
ils restaient éventuellement ça c'est
oui on n'a pas la dérive on n'a pas la
réponse officielle
ça reste de la sarre est de la rumeur il
dit il était question que certaines
équipes plus haut classé en fédérale 2
et fédérale 3 soit offert l'une pour
nous soit rétrogradé administrativement
dans le comité ile de france et que ça
libère à ce moment-là déplaçant en
fédérale 3 puisque ces équipes-là aurait
été aurait été rétrogradé soit en
honneur soit plus bas et et des équipes
de fédérale 3 cents à ce moment-là mutés
ou montée en division supérieure
la désormais il n'y a plus qu'une qu'une
équipe dont pour laquelle la question se
pose mais bon on va dire que
sportivement sportivement on a raté le
coche
donc là d'une pratiquement il reste
vraiment un très un très faible
pourcentage pour que ça se réalise est
ce qu'il ya des regrets sur cette saison
quand on voit le bilan finalement 10
victoires 1 nul et 7 défaites en
championnat après salaire un petit peu
mieux du coup dans tout ce qui est sûr
c'est la france mais j'ai eu quand même
ces défaite comme une tomate ils sont
théoriquement des retraites des regrets
notamment sur début de saison c'est à
dire qu'on a on a perdu en début de
en début de saison des matchs qu'on
n'aurait pas dû perdre il notamment
contre les concurrents directs à la
montée notamment à sarcelles et contre
sarcelles à la maison et contre contre
bagneux notamment le je pense au match 2
au match de sarcelles qu'on perd
finalement d'assez peu après avoir mis
une mi temps à se mettre dans le match
et quand ya que deux mi temps c'est
assez difficile de conclure positivement
donc oui des regrets sur les matches de
poule déjà on aurait peut-être pu se
frotter un petit peu plus tôt à
sarcelles et manu sur la course à la
montée directe en poule et puis quelques
regrets en phase finale pas celui de
sept qualifiés bien évidemment parce que
là on fait l'équipe
l'équipe de versailles fait un très beau
un terrain très beau parcours en phases
finales on l'a dit regret ou et
peut-être sur le match de chalon où on a
joué crânement notre notre chance à fond
et puis ça passe ça passe pas loin parce
que 11 010 avec quelques pénalités
laissé derrière ça laisse effectivement
quelques regrets vers la question est ce
qu'il y aura un gros mercato à
versailles d j'ai déjà mercato sur la
part travailler déjà on y travaille déjà
le mercato déjà sur les haies sur les
entraîneurs donc avec le staff qui
changent puisque le staff sortante
d'alain jamet s'inscrivait pas forcément
dans la durée de notre projet à trois
ans de montée en fédérale 3 et de s'y
maintenir ou à l'écran justement qui ne
sera plus l'entraîneur de verser à ses
employés
saiki et qui rebondira au puc c1 c'est
alain est un très bon entraîneur un très
bon pro et on s'est séparés évidemment à
regret de
de lui surtout après une saison on finit
en phase finale
l'objectif l'objectif de monter en
fédérale 3 n'est pas atteint cette
saison là on a encore une chance l'année
prochaine c'est là où on va la jouer à
fond
donc oui un an un nouveau staff
d'entraîneurs et puis et puis des
nouveaux joueurs qui seront sûrement
c'est qu'ils seront sûrement séduit par
le projet humain on verra ça en tout cas
dans les prochaines semaines merci à
vous d'être passé sur ce bateau on
continuera à suivre avec attention les
performances du rugby-club de versailles
les scènes s'enchaînent encore bravo
pour votre parcours en championnat de
france
est ce que vous êtes un fan de modélisme
pierre chevalier elle mobilise pas trop
je n'ai pas le temps pas trop patron à
partager cette passion l'a aux
miniatures peut-être un petit peu plus
en allant visiter le france miniature
voisins ont en tout cas le reportage qui
va suivre devrait quand même vous
intéressez un le mord pas modélisme club
a fait chauffer la gomme le ce week-end
en organisant la quatrième manche du
championnat de france de course de
voitures radiocommandées au total près
de cent pilotes venus de quatre coins de
l'hexagone se sont affrontés sur le
circuit de maurepas notre journaliste
nicolas dont réalité dans les paddocks
est sur le bord de la piste regardez les
moteurs tournent les voitures chauffer
les pneus lors du tour de formation
c'est la demi-finale de cette 4e manche
du championnat de france de voitures
radiocommandées les bolides à l'échelle
1 8e sur la piste de maurepas c'est un
circuit qui est assez rapide
les difficultés c'est les passages de
bosses et le circuit héros lieu d'être
en largeur ce qu'on trouve
habituellement il est plutôt en
profondeur donc en fait on objets mettre
les pilotes sur une zone surélevée à
trois mètres de hauteur pour qu'ils
puissent voir la voiture quand elle est
au fond la course dure 30 minutes le
pilote réalisant le plus de tours gagne
comme en formule un à un les stands et
les mécaniciens permettent de
ravitailler les véhicules en essence
avec des réglages stratégique
particulier comme alexis clément
vainqueur de cette manche on a beaucoup
travaillé sur les pneus une fois qu'on
avait trouvé notre base de
réglage de voitures scène voilà mes
difficultés de cette puce dirait
la longueur les deux virages au fond
là-bas sont loin et pour ceux qui ne
l'ont pas forcément rouler dessus
ouais je dirais ça la première
difficulté le morlaisien brice grosjean
a connu des difficultés de moteur il
repêché dans une course particulière le
premier est qualifié en finale
après quelques minutes brice réussi à
prendre la tête
[Musique]
s'ensuit une bagarre entre les bolides
miniatures avec une victoire finale de
brice et à le commentateur de la course
qui qui commande c'est déjà ça donne un
stress plus après le stress de la course
réussir à garder sa place de premier
après maurepas une nouvelle manche du
championnat de france se déroulera à
castres du 12 au 14 octobre 2018 nous
allons maintenant rangé des voitures
télécommandées à pour parler de cyclisme
les championnats de france sur route
sont organisées à mantes la jolie et à
partir de ce jeudi 28 juin jusqu'au
dimanche 1er juillet
au programme trois jours de compétitions
qui vont rassembler plus de 600 coureurs
dans des contre la montre des épreuves
en ligne
amateurs ou pros pour nous parler de
cette compétition nous avons le plaisir
de recevoir sur ce plateau emmanuel
brunet manager de la route au sein de la
direction technique nationale de la
fédération française de cyclisme bonsoir
bonsoir
emmanuel est ce que tout est prêt à
quelques jours quelques heures de
l'épreuve alors tout est prêt oui ça m'a
l'air prêt en tout cas on sent
l'effervescence monte dans les yvelines
et je crois que le département et tous
les services de la ville sont vraiment
active et là ces derniers temps pour
faire en sorte que la cette fête là ils
soient vraiment réussi et en plus la
météo sera là vous allez faire un tour
sur place pour voir comment tout se
passer des tours j'en ai fait énormément
dès le mois de novembre en fait d'abord
en voiture après en vélo pour filmer les
circuits faire les locaux officiels
locaux techniques puis avec la presse au
mois d'avril donc le circuit on commence
déjà à bien l'avoir à la barre alors
pour quelqu'un qui ne connaît pas du
tout ces championnats de france
est-ce que vous pouvez nous les
présentait alors une championne de
france en cyclisme au lieu de six en
compétition d'envergure
c'est une compétition d'envergure pour
la simple et bonne raison qu'elle est
une semaine avant le tour de france est
souvent en fait celui qui est champion
de france on va là on va voir son
maillot bleu-blanc-rouge sur le tour de
france et il s'est vraiment le lancement
de cette de cette saison estivale et
avec toujours beaucoup d'audience télé
beaucoup de monde au bord du circuit
voilà donc c'est un événement qui
rassemble là là à l'aube des vacances
d'été alors pourquoi mantes-la-jolie et
les yvelines cette année alors pourquoi
mantes-la-jolie pourquoi les yvelines ça
s'est décidé dans l'hiver dernier alors
il faut savoir que les yvelines c'est
assez exceptionnel en fait j'en passe de
france dans les yvelines déjà en ile de
france le dernier remontait dans les
années 90 à montlhéry et les yvelines
il faut remonter très très loin en
arrière je crois qu'aujourd'hui avec les
jeux olympiques qui seront là dans six
ans dans les yvelines
il ya un vrai engouement des des acteurs
locaux en fait pour accueillir des
événements d'envergure et voilà mantes
la jolie était il le département des
yvelines était ok pour accueillir cet
événement et se sont mis à pied d'oeuvre
pour pour le faire a dignement
est ce que la culture cyclisme des
yvelines a joué aussi dans le dossier de
candidature il ya eu les championnats du
monde sur piste en 2015 au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
il y à tous les ans depuis neuf ans
paris nice également qui passent dans
les yvelines
est ce que cette culture cycliste
finalement a fait pencher le dossier ivy
noir si c'est sur les yvelines comme
vous venez de signalisation y décroche
gros événement est de plus en plus en
fait avec le cyclisme avec le vélodrome
et 7
cet engouement pour les jeunes en
quelques années sûrement il ya également
la classique paris mantes qui est
vraiment connu en fait je pense par une
grande partie du peloton qui sera qui
sera au départ de cette épreuve la
classique particulière au mois d'avril
chi chi chi chi difficile parce qu'il ya
plein de petites côtes qui se succèdent
avec la présence du vent qui créent des
bordures est donc sacré des courses
digne digne des grandes classiques et je
pense que ce sera un petit peu ce goût
là qu'on aura
samedi dimanche sur les championnats
vous attendez combien de personnes sur
cet événement alors le nombre de
coureurs en fait c'est plus de 500
coureurs qui seront au départ de chaque
course et au niveau du public j'ai pas
trop d'idée je me rends pas compte ce
que je sais c'est que les coûts tels
seront remplies rempli de monde et la
soixante dix mille tonnes sur le bord
des routes
je pense à logements de plus il fera un
super beau c'est vraiment un chiffre
logique mantes-la-jolie et accessible en
plus on a des coins vraiment sympa
l'honneur de demandes sur fond la ville
et fontenay saint père ou à vous ce sera
très adapté pour venir avec la glacière
dès le matin et a passé la journée à
voir passer les coureurs aient profité
pour pique alors c'est un
événement très suivi sur la route mais
également la télévision à l'audience
moyenne sur france télévisions est de
1,5 million de téléspectateurs pour
l'épreuve hommes en moyenne est de 750
mille ha téléspectateurs pour les femmes
c'est une compétition vraiment qui
passionne c'est une compétition qui
passionne pendant un mois en fait on a
notamment les hommes se sont se prépare
pour le tour de france
les filles ont également d'autres
épreuves internationales au mois de
juillet comme je disais c'est vraiment
un tournant important et donc ouais ça
attire énormément de monde à regarder
cette épreuve
avant les grosses échéances de l'été
alors au niveau du programme je le
disais précédemment il ya des épreuves
en contre la montre et des épreuves en
ligne qui est ce qu'elle est l'épreuve
la plus attendue par le public
je pense que ce sont les épreuves en
ligne qui sont les plus attendues celles
qui ont le plus d'audience
c'est là où en fait la plus de bagarres
même si les contre la montre
voilà en france on progresse beaucoup
dans la discipline on aura 70 coureurs
hommes autant de professionnels que des
amateurs donc déjà des amateurs qui vont
se confronter aux pros et une
quarantaine de féminines avec certaines
qui sont également professionnelle donc
ça c'est toute la journée
pardon tout l'après midi de jeudi il ya
un contre la montre qui est assez
difficile qui en deux parties donc je
pense que ça peut attirer déjà beaucoup
de monde dès le jeudi et les circuits de
la course en ligne samedi et dimanche
ils sont vraiment favorable à des
courses d'attac et donc on peut avoir un
spectacle fantastique et parmi les têtes
d'affiché qui on retrouvera sur les
routes de montage mais celle et chez les
féminines on attend de revoir un peu
impolie n'a qu'à passer beaucoup de
temps à pauline ferrand prévôt part donc
à passer beaucoup de temps sur le vtt je
pense pas que ce soit le circuit trop à
son avantage mais voilà elle aura à
détricoter un peu les les grosses
équipes qui sont de plus en plus
nombreuses
notamment l'une des plus nombreuses ldj
nouvelle aquitaine futuroscope
et puis chez les hommes alors on
pourrait citer les locaux les galopins
les résas encore on accorde de briller
la fdj depuis quelques années fait une
mainmise sur le tableau sur le maillot
bleu blanc rouge
est ce que ce sera en eau de mer avec
une arrivée au sprint où un coureur plus
plus attaquant qui voudra l'emporter
voilà un peu les led affiche merci
beaucoup
emmanuel brunet on vous souhaite de bons
championnats de france sur route pour
moi alors je vous rappelle les dates
quand même le rendez vous sont organisés
de ce jeudi à 28 juin au dimanche 1er
juillet à mantes-la-jolie un tout autre
sujet à présent si les postures du
guerrier de la salutation au soleil ou
du chat n'ont plus de secret pour vous
le reportage qui va sud devrait attirer
votre attention pour les autres ce sera
le moyen de découvrir le yoga ce sport
originaire d'inde était proposé dans une
séance découverte à montigny le
bretonneux ce dimanche pour la deuxième
année consécutive un reportage monté par
le très zen junh jules grevy lé rendre
le yoga plus visible c'est l'objectif à
montigny le bretonneux le 24 juin
c'était journée découverte au centre
pierre de coubertin deux associations de
yoga ont accueilli les adeptes d'un jour
90 personnes pour s'initier gratuitement
à l'activité
c'est la deuxième journée que nous
faisons que nous organisons à montigny
depuis l'année dernière c'est un moyen
de faire connaître de yoga à un parent
population une deuxième journée
internationale du yoga montini sous
l'égide de l'ambassade indienne l'inde
est le pays d'origine du yoga il y
occupe toujours une place très
importante
ndiaye en inde c'est un mode de vie un
mode de vie j'entends une pratique
complète qui s'insère dans notre façon
de vivre
quand nous sommes à bout fatigue est
incapable d'être attentif nous
concentrons sur le souffle nous faisons
du yoga c'est notre moyen pour être
tranquille une planète qui passe elle
souhaite détente musculaire meilleure
gestion des émotions le yoga semble
séduire en france mais ne fait pas du
yoga qui veut patience régularité
encadrement sont nécessaires pour cette
activité
si le yoga procurent des bienfaits il
reste d'abord pour exigeant en fait
le yoga est bon pour le dos maintenant
quand il ya des blessures quand il ya
des hernies discales des douleurs
chroniques
on demande de toute façon pour la
pratique toujours un certificat médical
c'est important et puis après ben c'est
aussi au port aux personnes de respecter
leurs limites c'est à dire que le yoga
s'adapte à la personne et non l inverse
vu le succès rencontré cette année les
organisateurs pourraient de nouveau
organisé une journée de ce type l'an
prochain on prend maintenant la
direction de buc une jeune joueuse de
tennis prometteuse est en train de faire
de plus en plus de bruit dans les
yvelines
originaire de serbie et hewitt chastan
commis tchétchènes les belles
performances avec son club de buc son
objectif intégrer un jour le top 20
mondial
un montage du richard gasquet du montage
xavier jaglin y vite ça c'est un comique
11 ans j'aimerais intégrer le top 20
mondial
cette jeune tenniswoman d'origine serbe
a débuté le tennis à l'âge de quatre ans
évolue aujourd'hui au tennis-club de buc
sa passion pour ce sport est née en
regardant les matchs de son idole novak
djokovic vainqueur de douze titres du
grand chelem et coup vite il a d un bon
service sont cons enfin ces points c'est
ses coups droits à servins et son soirée
tout même quand il a mal et c'est quand
même deux
bien joué pour tenter de s'approcher de
la technique du serbe ljubica s'entraîne
deux fois par semaine en double et en
simple pendant 1h30 avec ses coachs la
sportive réalise également des matches
avec son équipe qui évolue en troisième
division des yvelines je pense qu'elle
est assez motivé qu'il ya des choses qui
sont assez prometteuse chez dans son jeu
notamment
voilà son point fort qui le coup droit
ou là un bon bras et donc voilà il ya
des bonnes choses et j'espère qu'il va
continuer à être motivée parce que dans
une bonne progression en parallèle des
cours de tennis son père dejan ancien
joueur de haut niveau l'aide également
dans sa progression en s'entraînant avec
elle plusieurs fois par mois dont la
famille mais les glandes amateurs de
tennis moi je jouais quand je nage entre
les 15 et 18 ans 19 ans dans notre pays
d'origine en ex yougoslavie
si les beats avec moi qu'il valait plus
la balle donc mais qui est et qui a les
joues sont pas qu'au dit comment tirer
quand même placé canfin europe à ce que
je dois me replacer
-plus d'un côté de l'autre comme ça des
conseils que you betcha devrait mettre
en application pour réaliser ses plus
grands rêves et pourquoi pas remporter
un jour un tournoi majeur
comme un certain novak djokovic nous
allons maintenant rangé les raquettes
pour parler de golf l'open de france
débute ce jeudi sur les greens du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
jusqu'à ce dimanche il y aura du beau
monde sur ce rendez-vous qui appartient
désormais aux rolex series les meilleurs
tournois européens
le vainqueur de l'an dernier le
britannique tommy fleetwood tentera de
défendre son titre
le public pourra également observer le
numéro un français alexander levy les
espagnols john ram et sergio garcia
mais l'attraction de cette journée
devrait être justin thomass le numéro
deux mondial 25 ans nouvelle pépite
défaire ou et américains pour observer
toutes ses stars les premières parties
sont programmés dès le jeudi matin
[Musique]
une dernière information au goal fiq
dans ce magazine un nouveau tournoi
prestigieux pourrait être organisée au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la fédération
française va déposer un dossier de
candidature pour organiser les
championnats du monde amateurs par
équipes
une compétition organisée tous les deux
ans et qui rassemble 1000 joueurs ce ne
sera pas une première le golf situé à
guyancourt a déjà reçu l'épreuve en 1994
cette année là il y avait un certain
tiger woods sur les greens saint
quentinois
la france devrait être en concurrence
avec le canada pour l'organisation de
cette épreuve internationale
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]